jusque dans leur vie personnelle
beaucoup de policiers redoublent
désormais de précautions pour ne pas se
faire repérer ils choisissent par
exemple d'habiter loin de leur secteur
d'affectation pour garantir la sécurité
de leurs familles les enfants eux
évitent de dire le métier que font leurs
parents par peur des représailles à
l'école et la haine du flic a changé de
dimension depuis les émeutes déclenchés
par la mort de Naël à Nanterre quant aux
policiers mis en cause dans la ferme son
nom et son adresse ont été diffusées sur
les réseaux sociaux sa femme et son fils
ont été placées 24 heures sur 24 sous
protection ils ont dû déménager du
premier hôtel dans lequel ils avaient
trouvé refuge pour aller dans un endroit
tenu secret certains vont jusqu'à faire
fuer les adresses postales des policiers
récupérer dans les fichiers de salle de
sport qui offrent des réductions en
policiers sur présentation de leur carte
professionnelle un délit plus mis de 5
ans d'emprisonnement et 75000 euros
d'amende lorsque la divulgation de
données personnelles vise une personne
dépositaire de l'autorité publique les
femmes de policiers et de gendarmes
elles doivent aussi prendre leur
précautions certaines se sont suivies et
s'inquiètent pour leurs enfants on avait
déjà peur quand nos maris policiers
étaient en service mais on a peur
désormais tout le temps jusque dans nos
foyers certains font tout pour remonter
jusqu'à leur adresse à Vénissieux un
homme a été interpellé alors qu'il
relevait des plaques d'immatriculation
des véhicules des policiers Gary à
proximité du commissariat selon un
officier anonyme même si la chasse aux
flics n'est pas généralisée les
collègues sont sur le qui-vive et
veulent de plus en plus rentrer avec
leur arme de service à la maison surtout
cette haine antiphlique prospère sur les
réseaux sociaux ou des vidéos
d'agressions contre les forces de
l'ordre sont publiées sans filtre et un
motif bien d'autres ce serait une erreur
d'accuser l'outil au lieu de voir qu'il
n'est que le symptôme d'un effondrement
éducatif lutter contre l'asservissement
de l'attention des jeunes aux écrans
supposent de comprendre qu'il est le
résultat du vide intérieur que l'échec
de l'école a laissé prospérer parmi les
647 policiers blessés depuis le début
des émeutes plusieurs l'ont été en
dehors de leurs services ce qui a
d'ailleurs poussé Gérald Darmanin le
ministre de l'Intérieur a prévenir la
prochaine personne qui touche à un
policier ou un gendarme qu'il sache
qu'il sera retrouvé et j'espère condamné
avec une très grande force
[Musique]